so as an fbi agent one of the things
that i would do
to make people comfortable was i always
made sure
that they would sit next to the door you
know on television
you always see the suspect sitting in
the corner of the room
that is third grade interviewing
graduate level interviewing is
you sit them near the door why there's
greater psychological
comfort there
my name is joe navarro and for 25 years
i was a
spy catcher with the fbi and i am a
non-verbal communications expert so
here's the truth about
detecting deception or detecting if
somebody is lying
there is no pinocchio effect it is sheer
nonsense
to assume that if somebody touches their
nose
clears their throat or touches their ear
that they're being deceptive and i think
this is the first time i'm revealing
this
on video what we look for are indicators
of discomfort and distress we're not
looking for deception
because there is no single behavior
indicative of deception
one of my favorite stories that's in my
book
what everybody is saying is of a woman
that was invited to the fbi office
because she was part of an investigation
and during the first
20 minutes or so that we in the fbi used
to calm the person down
this individual instead of calming down
became even more stressed and we hadn't
even talked about the case
she was biting her lip she was touching
her
her super sternal notch she was
clutching at her
neck jewelry a couple of times there she
was wringing her hands and finally
i said to her madam you look like you
need to get something off your chest
and she said thank you mr navarro
because when i parked downstairs
i only had two tokens for the meter and
the meter's about to run out
so here were all these behaviors that
maybe 30 years ago people would have
looked at and said oh
this is indicative of deception i mean
she's touched her nose she's bitter lip
no she was worried about getting a
ticket
because she didn't have enough coins
when she parked downstairs and as it
turns out
somebody had stolen her id she had
nothing to do with a crime
whether we're dealing with the honest or
the dishonest
we may see behaviors that are indicative
of psychological discomfort the only
thing that we can do
is try to determine why we are seeing
those behaviors
but not assume that they're indicative
of deception because the science just is
not
there one of the things that i would do
to make people comfortable was to say
look
i'm an fbi agent we're conducting an
investigation
and obviously you're here for a reason
my tone was always to go
lower and slower to make sure that at a
subconscious level they began to relax
what we want is someone who is calmer
so that we have better recall remember
when we create
stress we're affecting their memory and
this is why when we have stress we can't
remember where the keys are
so we want the person to calm down so we
put them near the door and we don't sit
too close to them
because when we violate space it makes
people
nervous so we back away from them
probably somewhere between four and five
feet away
which is really unusual because on
television
we're used to seeing people very up
close and then rather than make a lot of
eye contact
which is very intimidating what i would
do is
make less eye contact so that
they would begin to relax and then i
would do cathartic exhales
so i would look at my notes and do
something like this
at a subconscious level the person
listening to me
will actually mirror that because
humans gravitate towards homeostasis
then i begin with very simple things i
would say
tell me about your name it gives them an
opportunity to say well
my father his grandmother was named this
way
and now the person is relating
subconsciously to these positive things
that have occurred in their life
and they're bringing it forward which
also contributes to
psychological comfort
so are there times when we
need to create psychological pressure
that is a profound
question i don't recommend it because
once you create psychological pressure
we know that it takes anywhere from a
half hour to an hour
to return that person back to normal or
homeostasis
after doing 13 000 interviews i can tell
you
i have never seen where
escalating a situation has benefited
anyone what it has done is it has
derailed me
as an interviewer to the point where i
remember
there was an espionage interview i was
doing on someone that was accused of
espionage
and it was a bizarre interview it was
done standing up
over three and a half hours on the
loading dock
of a lumber yard in
georgia myself and the suspect were
going back and forth
and i was just getting more and more
frustrated
and the man was sticking to the same
story
and i was beginning to lose my patience
i had to end the interview because
at that point i wasn't thinking clearly
and as it turns out this individual
did not commit espionage his repetition
of the same story
was consistent with what really happened
he didn't do it
and so this was one of those mid-career
type situations where it validated that
thinking once again that raising your
voice creating stress
is not beneficial at all
what do you know about those stolen
jewels when i came into
law enforcement in 1975 i was going
through the utah police academy and they
were teaching back then that if somebody
touched their nose
touched their mouth or cough they were
lying this is sheer
and absolute nonsense and they were
taught teaching this for the for decades
and even when i entered the fbi in 1979
there were still misconceptions about
well if somebody
asks for a drink of water or if they
look up and to the left and then they
look to the right
that they're creating or uh inventing an
answer and so forth and the fact of the
matter is that is
all garbage there were any number of
things that we were falsely told
we that were indicative of deception
from facial touching to sniffing
rubbing the insides of our mouths with
our tongue and so forth here's the
downside to all of this
i looked at the 261
dna exonerations that took place
over the last few decades and this was
the initial review of these individuals
who had been convicted and were
sentenced to
be executed and dna
later proved that they had nothing to do
with the crime
and here's what's sad in every single
case not one not one police officer
not one prosecutor could detect
the truth but they all claimed
to be able to detect deception the other
thing we found that was interesting from
those 261
dna exonerations fully 25
was willing to admit to a crime just to
stop the interview process
that means that those interviews where
there was a lot of psychological
pressure applied
where it took place over hours and hours
and hours
where there was a lot of threatening
demeanor
that eventually the people were willing
to say you know what
just to you know i'm going to admit it
even though it's going to cost me my
life
25 that's frightening so every time i
hear
somebody out there says i can tell that
they're lying from their their body
language i just say that's
absolute rubbish there is no science to
support it
all right ralph you want it the hard way
i can fix that too you've got 20 years
staring you right in the face
what do you want me to say that i did it
we're always dealing with a human brain
whether we're dating whether we're
dealing with family members or
even in a forensic interview you know i
tell the story of this individual in
yuma arizona
who immediately came under suspicion
there was a
body found and the person had been
stabbed with an ice pick
now the only person that knew this
was myself and the suspect
we found out that the victim had been in
an argument with
this individual named ricky so you know
i go and meet with ricky
and uh ricky said i had nothing to do
with it
and i said well that's fine i said well
ricky
you tell me you didn't kill this
gentleman but if you had
would you have used a machete and he
said no
i said okay would you have used a gun no
how about an axe
no and i said ricky would you have used
an ice pick
and when i used the word ice pick which
obviously somebody with guilty knowledge
would respond to
his eyelids came down and he tucked his
chin
in blocking behavior protective behavior
so i just looked at him and i said ricky
come on
you were seen having an argument with
him and now he's dead
and uh and eventually he confessed keep
in mind that
nonverbal communications per se are not
admissible in court i mean i could say
that the person looked distraught
and defense counsel might ask well how
would you know that
how long have you known the person what
does distraught look like
and i could say well i you know he
closed his eyes and he lowered his
chin and they could come back and say
well
that's not indicative of anything but
this is how we use nonverbals
to let me know that that which only the
suspect
knew affected him
there's a certain amount of lying that
we have to do to get along with each
other so we say that
lying is a tool for social survival and
because of that
we're actually pretty good at lying most
of us
lie the research says anywhere
from three to five times an hour i
hardly talk to anyone
in an hour so i don't think i find
myself
lying so much but i know that if you
know i'm having a bad day and somebody
says hey how are you i'll probably say
yeah i'm okay
when i'm not i think the most effective
liars
are the people who habitually lie one of
the best liars i ever ran into was a
woman
who was a spy she could tell
stories like no one i've ever known they
were so convincing
you would ask her a question and she
would just
be so fluid in her answers and of course
she's describing something that was
taking place in germany
so it's not something that we could go
and check on the next day
and she let us on for about a year the
only thing that we can do
to protect ourselves from deception is
what is being said and what is the proof
you begin to make an inquiry the story
begins to
fall apart or it causes a cognitive load
you know oh so you you went to uh to
mexico
which airport did you land that um i
you know and then they struggle to come
out with with an
answer simple questions should evoke
simple answers
and when they create a cognitive load
then it's not indicative of deception
but it should certainly make you wonder
is there something wrong here one of the
things about this
woman spy who was in fact convicted 25
years
as soon as we were in germany and
allowed to conduct the investigation
we could immediately see that the story
was falling apart
you can either accept a story as it's
being told
or you can make an effort to question it
to see if you can verify it
there's a lot of myths about body
language
but this one area this area of deception
we've got to get away from this because
this is no
joke you can be sued for saying to
somebody
i think you're lying when it's based on
non-verbals
and you can certainly ruin somebody's
life in fact i would say anybody that
says
i can help you to detect deception
is actually deceiving you because there
just simply is no science to support it
all we can say is we're seeing behaviors
indicative of psychological discomfort
and that is as far
as you can go with that